let me ask you about things with Tyler
that's only been 2 months ago and so my
feelings just don't go away awkward that
was Hannah be talking all things Tyler
see with et just last week but now
things seem to be heating up between
Tyler si and Gigi Hadid yeah you heard
that right
Gigi freakin Hadid is this legit is it
confirmed good on Tyler a source tells
ET Gigi and Tyler hit up frames bowling
lounge in NYC on Monday night nothing
says love like the bowling alley am i
right the bowling date came less than 24
hours after the two were first spotted
together leaving the Dumbo house in
Brooklyn separately but they both got
into GG's chauffeured SUV and get this
went back to her apartment fans of The
Bachelorette may be shook but they
aren't totally surprised
while the hit ABC show was airing fans
actually noticed that Gigi followed
Tyler on Instagram and the timing of
these two outings is well it's
interesting just days ago Tyler was
spotted leaving hanabi's house after
spending the night with her the whole
Hanabi Tyler C thing has been drama
since the get-go on the finale of The
Bachelorette we learned Hanna picked Jed
over Tyler but that didn't last where
does your relationship stand now I
and not with Chad any more then Hannah
asked Tyler out during after the final
rose
I just thought maybe we could go for a
drink and just hang it I would love to
just tell me what
did you just ask Tyler out on a date you
guys are gonna give this yourself I want
to continue to be a part of his life and
I think he wants to be a part of mine
but at what capacity I don't think we
know you just yet
but excited to see him and catch up okay
so we know they got their ketchup
session in and when et caught up with
Hanna on Monday she dished on what
really went down that night you guys got
that drink huh yeah I had a jerk yeah I
had some drinks I had some drinks this
vegan okay did you and Tyler hung out we
saw the photos how did it go
I have a great time we definitely hung
out and talked about everything and I
know nobody will believe me just hanging
out and actually talking what did you
guys decide about your next steps or
your future are you as soon as as what
we've been saying okay we are trying to
figure out where this like how we feel
I've said to you to a lot of like I saw
feelings but I'm also single and he's
single and I want to keep my options
open and he can keep his options I have
been and there are still rumors swirling
around that Tyler could be the next
Bachelor I think it'd be a little hard
to see him as a bachelor because there
still feelings there but I would support
him in his happiness I think that is the
main thing it's figuring out what will
make both of us happy he was with Chris
Harrison on Monday and he explained how
Tyler's outings with Gigi could affect
his chances of being the next Bachelor
Tyler you know a lot of fandom for his
bachelor then him and Hannah are getting
a drink then he's reportedly on a date
with supermodel Gigi Hadid what does a
gigi hadid
moment do for Tyler's chances for
bachelor something like that we're
definitely way in the conversation and
so yeah if Tyler is bouncing around from
girl to girl and loving the life and
enjoying the limelight which by the way
good on him that's fine if that's what
you want to do right now I don't blame
him he's probably enjoying life
really
really well but that's not someone we're
gonna want him have his our
bachelor/bachelorette this is so
dramatic
even by bachelor standards and I am here
for it guys of course we'll be right
here to fill you in on all the juicy
details so make sure to keep it locked
right here on ET until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]